Hello everybody!
Hello!
I hope the music is not too loud because, oh my god, it is
very loud on my hand.
Hello everybody!
I cannot believe it.
We're finally going to play the best Sonic game ever created
which I've yet to ever, which I've never played before.
That's when you know that it is a really good game because
even i know this is the best sonic game ever but okay it's a
little loud let me turn that down shift down don't worry it
was very loud for me too look this game was made in like the
the 90s okay like there was no like sound balancing or like
mixing like sound mixing and balancing in game was not a
thing back in the 90s guys just to remember see it was made
in 96 97 98 and 99 so game audio balancing was not a thing
back then the 90s were a different time guys uh many thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you it's like a car
crash i don't what do you mean this this in my opinion is no
i feel like in my opinion uh sonic dreams collection is one
of the best Sonic game collection they have ever made.
Each one, Make My Sonic, Eggman Origin, Sonic Movie Maker,
and my roommate Sonic, I would say, like, all of them, 10
out of 10.
Never played either any of them before.
But, like, just reading the names, I can tell that it is a
10 out of 10 game.
So, for those who are wondering, like, what is the lore?
behind Sonic Dreams Collection.
Well, obviously, none of us, obviously, like, not a lot of
us grew up with Sonic Dreams Collection, but I've heard
that, like, these games were released only back then for,
like, one year, like, when it was released, it was only out
for a limited time.
So, like, not a lot of people were able to actually play
these games back then in 96, 97, 98, 99 so they recently
re-released it like 10 years ago
it was recently re-released 10 years ago so so those who
didn't grow up back then um to be able to play these games
missed out on what was considered Sonic gaming so it's been
10 years yes it has been almost 10 years since the
collection came out also by the way so like wait who Sega so
I was gonna be like who made Sonic Sega contracted these
developers because back then Sega was like, we should hire
American developers to make a Sonic game.
So they contacted these developers.
And after making what was known as one of the best Sonic
collection games ever, they went on to make Tadotel and Neon
White.
Is that crazy?
I can't believe.
No wonder.
No wonder Neon White was so good.
They came from dream collection they can never miss
they don't miss they knew what the consumer wants back in
the 90s and now they know what the consumer wants in the
2023 so true they don't miss uh court jester thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you I've never heard of the
best Sonic game there is can't wait to experience it through
you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
I've never played this game before but like through word of
mouth from the people who played it in the 90s I I heard it
was a really good I've been I've been wanting to play this
game for a very long time But it was just so perfect that
was very hard to be able to like play play it at its current
time because like you know they wanted to they released
re-released it 10 years ago and like they want to keep they
want to keep the peak gaming experience 10 years ago
untouched because you had to be there in the moment when it
was re-released so it was very hard to play it now But now,
now I can.
Now I can.
Now we get to finally experience this game with all of you.
Sonic 06 is better.
Lies!
Sonic 06 wishes it was just as good as my roommate Sonic.
They wish they were just as good as my roommate Sonic.
I have not played before but I believe that my roommate
Sonic has has the best beginning middle and end it's rich
with story and Sonic oh sick wishes it has two percent of my
roommate Sonic it wishes it has the the like it wishes it
can be as good as roommate Sonic oh my god Never played it
before, but I know it's just as good.
True and real.
Was my sound guy alive?
I don't even know if my sound guy is alive.
Sound guy!
How's...
You know it's good when the resolution is 1280x960.
Okay.
That's when you know When the resolution is pure retro
That's when you know it's a good game It is Sound guy, how's
the sound?
Is the music good enough?
Sound guy Look, look, see?
I have like endorsements As a turn, thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you As a true Sonic fan, this
collection Was a life-changing experience It really makes
you feel like Sonic.
See?
Look at that.
Sound guy, just type to me in the chat.
Because I have your modded so I can see it.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
I have endorsements.
I have like witnesses.
Wait, what's that word?
What's that word when someone is vouchers?
I have vouchers from real Sonic fan.
Anyway, it's time to make my Sonic.
Make my Sonic was MJ Studio's first prototype.
with Sega, a Sonic OC original character creator.
MJ Studio was committed to fan self-expression.
They believed that Sonic was versatile enough for every
genre, even sci-fi.
Originally, Make My Sonic was meant to create and upload
avatars for use with every Dreamcast through SegaNet.
Sadly, no future games supported this level of creativity.
Oh my gosh.
Honestly, I feel like Sonic peaked it.
and make my Sonic.
They try to do that with the, what was it, the A-force
Sonic?
Because I forgot, remember that Sonic game they made where
you create your OC in Sonic, but then it was like, it was so
bad.
Was it Sonic Forces?
Yeah, Sonic Forces.
You know, they, they knew, they knew they could never make,
make my Sonic.
They, they try to repeat perfection, but they couldn't,
didn't like recreate perfection uh dark blade thank you for
the magenta soup but thank you thank you doki when i was
hoping you played more sonic games i really didn't mean this
what do you mean of course what do you mean i would start
off with the best sonic game they've ever made why would you
say that dark blade are you trying to say make my sonic 96
where we can make my our very own sonic original character
it's not peak gaming how could you say that we all want to
have a sonic
Let's go.
All right.
What do we want?
We want a small head.
Oh.
Turtle the king.
Cheating.
All right.
How about.
Okay.
Small head for small hitbox.
You know.
I'm trying to.
No headshot.
You know.
Is there yellow?
Yellow Sonic?
All right.
Yellow Sonic.
Where?
I want to be yellow Sonic.
All right.
Yellow.
Sonic.
Okay, background color.
Uh, you know what?
All yellow.
That'll be good.
All...
Oh, they don't even have yellow?
How can they have yellow Sonic, but no yellow?
Also, is that why your colors match?
Exactly!
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Exactly, Yoko.
Now you're thinking Sonic right now.
Now you're thinking Sonic.
Oh, there's a yellow background!
Oh, wait, I can move this.
Wait, I can pose for...
Um...
I can pose.
Can I, like...
Is this all...
Okay, I can just move this.
Okay.
Alright, I wanna...
Alright.
You know what?
You're levitating Sonic.
You know, you can figure out your Sonic OC by, like, putting
your name in Google and then writing, like, Doki the
Hedgehog.
And then you can have your own very own Sonic OC.
Apparently, every name has a Sonic OC at this point.
Alright.
What do I...
Okay.
Okay, he's gonna be running.
He's a runner.
Alright.
What is... What is our...
Oh, okay, cheap.
Okay, I can't type.
Sorry, back in the 90s, it was very hard to code in.
It was very hard to code in, like, the ability to type your
name.
So, unfortunately, they had to make, like, custom names for
everybody.
But there were so many custom names that you can pick from
that like everybody had like their own name you know look
back in 96 back in 96 it was it was very hard there was only
like five megabytes okay like each each like CD for oh god
Sonic 2 thank you for the super chat many thank you thank
you each CD for like computer gaming can only house five
megabytes guys so like of course there was like no option to
uh yeah if you're lucky if you're lucky five megabytes so so
back then um it's hard to code in the ability to type your
name in uh in in gaming uh yeah five whole megabytes i
actually don't want this color let's do like let's do like
you know what i would like it to be dark like my heart chibi
cassidy the mortal hedgehog solar prego met metal zenshi the
king supreme vocaloid hedgehog um yes vocaloid wait went to
Vocaloid as we all know Vocaloid came out in 1996 so like
they wanted to like capitalize on the Sonic fandom because
Sonic was very popular back then so the first prototype of
Vocaloid was in Make My Sonic
I don't know if you knew that guys A little fun fact A
little fun fact Like before Hatsune Miku It was It was
Before Before Hatsune Miku It was So Dio Kusumita The rebel
vocaloid hedge girl But they realized that it was too long
so they they were like why don't we combine all these
letters in that name and make it hasunemiku um and that's
how we got our first vocaloid um is that crazy oh my god
that's crazy i can't believe we're learning so much today
about Sonic history.
Yes, the Sonic lore.
Knight Goldie Diyoshino the Hedgy.
Alien Metal Dragon Synth the Hedgehog.
Knight Cassie the Supreme Hedgehog.
Jewels the Immortive Supreme Hedgehog.
Oh my god, there's so many possibilities.
There's so many names.
Venus Fox the Princess Hedgy.
Knight Nocturne the Hedgehog.
Wind is the Hedgehog.
Dragon Blackles.
What the fuck is Blackles?
The Immortal Rebel Hedgy.
Soul Alex.
The, okay.
Rouge.
Silver.
The Vocaloid Hedgy.
You know what?
I, I, I think like.
We're getting so much Vocaloids.
That like is.
Oh shit.
Sexy outfit.
Sinia the Supreme Hedgy.
Okay.
You know what?
I like this one.
This is my Sonic OC.
Sexy.
Just so you guys know.
This is sexy.
This is like peak sexy.
this right there okay this is why my stream is at least pg15
it's just way too hot to handle anyway i've the ideal peak
hedgehog right here all right photo booth time okay ring oh
okay i can throw rings at myself oh okay next cam oh all
right next cap oh nice yes that's where all the sexiness
lies i'm really scared about taking screenshots so i'm gonna
hide my oh okay all right good okay i had to i had to make
sure that like it doesn't do anything weird all right let's
take a picture oh that's great i'm gonna tweet this out guys
give me a sec let me tweet this out real fast tweet photo i
made my sonic own sonic let's see Get out.
Thanks, Arcane Kids.
I have to connect my account.
You know what?
I'll do it.
No!
I forgot it's 96!
Sorry, back then.
I just need you guys to know.
Back then, there was a Twitter beta.
So, like, only people who have Sonic Dreams Collection, only
people who access MakeMySonic had the access to, like,
Twitter beta.
So, like...
they first tested out twitter on make my sonic uh because
they wanted to see what it was like to connect your game to
like twitter so it was like the first twitter connection i
know not only they just don't make twitter like they do in
96 like i know wikipedia said twitter came out but after 96
um back yeah back in 96 it was called Twitter.
I know like all these like youngins are like, what's
Twitter?
Are you talking about X?
Back in 96, X was actually called Twitter.
And they had an exclusive deal with Make My Sonic to test
out some features where you can connect your account to
twitter.com.
And so, it was like the first Twitter photos and it's true
it's true you can look it up in the Sonic Wikipedia it's so
true anyway let's upload to Sega net well no what do you
mean no adapter detected how else would anyone know about
sexy outfit seen as a supreme hedgy how would they know
how would all the other hedgehog been how would all the
other sonic fanatics know about my beautiful creation the
world must know skittles thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i missed this triple a sonic game sega will
remain as cowards for never acknowledging this game's
potential but i know sonic sega music are the goat thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you i will not be
silenced i'm gonna screenshot this i need you all to see my
my sonic oc give me a All right, there we go.
Now the world knows my Sonic OC thing.
Perfect.
The world knows now.
All right, the world must know.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
What is printable mode?
What is...
Oh, what is...
wait color my oc color my sonic oc guys it's like a coloring
book it's literally a free coloring book oh my god things
were so fucking better in 96 where is my printable mode in
power world where is my printable mode in uh sonic forces in
sonic boom i can't believe it You guys were like, no, Sonic
06 is a better Sonic game than make my Sonic OC.
But where is my printable mode?
Huh?
Where was it?
How was I supposed to color Sonic the Hedgehog?
Huh?
She's got a point.
I can't believe we never had that.
Oh my god.
Anyway, um, uh, I hope you guys enjoy the first game.
Oh, sorry about the Sonic Dream Collection.
I hope you guys in...
You know it's official when Sonic says that.
You know, it's official.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
My OC.
My OC is not on SegaNet.
All the other Sonic OC fans can't comment on my beautiful OC
now.
I'm so I'm so sad this is truly the gold era of gaming it
can't possibly get better can it well the great thing about
these American developers is that every year they've outdone
themselves it's actually crazy if you guys thought make my
sonic was that great you should check out Eggman origin
never played it but I assume every game gets better from
what I've heard is known about Eggman Origin.
There's no surviving documentation.
From digging through the code, we can tell it was an MMORPG.
A few have ever seen past the title screen.
Oh my god, we're gonna be one of the few!
Guys, it is such an honor to play Eggman Origins for all of
you.
Sonic MMORPG.
Eggman Origins.
Wait, what?
No network adapter connected.
How do I get this?
Wait.
Guys, how do we...
How do we turn on...
Wait, I didn't install the network adapter?
Guys!
How do I install the network adapter?
It's so ancient!
This...
This game is so ancient!
How do I get the network adapter?
Wait a...
Okay, guys.
I gotta hook it up to top.
Yeah.
We gotta go back to 96.
We gotta go back to 96?
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta find the network adapter.
Okay, maybe it's in make added Twitter support.
okay okay i had to download it oh my okay wait guys i need a
fine then don't worry don't worry don't worry i've
downloaded everything there is to when i bought sonic dreams
collection by the way it was so difficult to like buy this
collection because it's like technically like abandonware
you know so like i had to like go on ebay and like buy the
cd to play this game and like i had to it was so hard to get
a physical copy of sonic dream collection and i had to spend
so much money on ebay to wait i got mail where did i got
mail i i had to spend so much money trying to find a
physical copy because it's like from 96 you know Like, how?
Of course it's gonna be difficult.
It's literally from 96.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need to find a way to... Okay, Sonic Dream Collection.
Where the fuck is the adapter?
Where is the adapter, guys?
Give me a sec.
I am going through some stuff because I don't know where the
adapter is right now.
I don't know.
Some things are meant to be lost.
What do you mean?
This is known as one of the best Sonic games of our
generation and like pre-generation of any generation it is
the best Sonic game ever anyway how do I get the network
adapter
I got it I got it install MSN messenger the driver is in the
CD where in the CD do I take the CD CD out?
It's in the game files.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
Sorry.
I didn't grow up with Sonic.
It's okay.
Thank God we have people that have grown up with the Sonic
Dream Collection that has the step-by-step guide.
Uh, step-by-step guide on how to get these games running.
Uh, Nick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your sponsorship with Sega has been revoked because you play
this.
That is how could they revoke my sponsorship with Sega when
this is an official an official game from Sega Company?
How is that possible?
It's one of their most it's one of their most
well-performing games.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Everyone talked about Sonic Dream Collection.
Any naughty kids in my chat?
Tell me about your, tell me about your experience with the
Sonic Dream Collection.
Any naughty kids in the chat vouching for me.
Okay, let me see.
I'm trying to figure out how to fuck to download the, okay,
let me, there's a read me text.
Clearly I didn't read the read me text.
Oh shit, okay, wait a minute.
Okay.
all right wait wait okay give me a sec i'm trying to figure
out i'm trying to figure out how to download the adapt guys
i need a step-by-step guide how do i get the how do i get
the adapter guys oh my god it did take the screenshot i
found the screenshot though oh it's extra data files Oh my
god, I'm still, okay, extra unsafe file.
Wait, isn't the unsafe file used at your own risk?
Oh my god, all right, we can use this.
We're gonna use at our own risk.
Okay, after that, you'll find the, let's do, okay, unsafe
file, use at my own risk.
Okay, I got that.
What do I do after that?
Oh my god, I already lost the step-by-step guide that you
guys gave me.
Corrupted data, okay, corrupted data.
All right, oh, there you go, Saganet!
net all right i'm installing stag in it right now okay we
have to create a username uh
joke jokie bird um don't hack into my stag in it it's one
two three four password wait it doesn't work what guys one
two three four it doesn't work
Doki Brut is already taken?
Who took my account?
The code is hidden in 98.
All right, sorry.
Unfortunately, we won't be able to...
We'll figure it out.
We'll go to Sonic Movie Maker.
All right.
Sonic Movie Maker was many years ahead of its time.
Technically speaking, MJ Studio envisioned a movie making
program for players to explore and share their desires with
the rest of the world.
Internal, the 90s Doki Bird took my account.
Doki Bird from 96.
Internal notes suggest that Sega executives pulled the plug
after learning about some of Sonic movie makers' darker
subplots.
Don't worry those who had FOMO were able to grab a copy of
Sonic Movie Maker So this was like a partnership with
Microsoft Because like you know how like some companies want
to add like a little spice To like a little crossover collab
So like Microsoft Movie Maker Collabed with Sonic with Sega
to make like a Sega skin for like movie maker So uh so
that's great It was like really easy back then to like make
movies Look at that.
Oh my god, the Sonic movie maker.
It was the precursor for Miku-Miku's That's Good Times.
Alright.
Let's make a movie, Sonic.
Woo!
Okay, how do I play?
Apprendel-er-er-glass.
basic control okay controls basic is all right WAC move okay
left is left is grab oh left mouse click is grab uh middle
mouse middle is grab the pop prop push and pull and then
right is record okay record while in record mode uh record
zoom exit okay additional escape grab object cycle filters
water tips a steady hand is the first step to a great film
hold right click to enter record mode and steady the camera
once you're done filming walk through the red exit door to
show sonic you're satisfied with the day's shoot while
grabbing the prop you can use the scroll wheel to pull or
push it use the e-key to grab objects while filming sonic
and his pals love right witch thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you sonic dreams collection marked the end
of my childhood innocence after playing it i was no longer a
mere girl i was a hedgehog and i was fast thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you look at that a 90s kid
vouched for my for this game you can always trust 90s kids
they've been through a lot all right let's go to the
Welcome to Sonic Movie Maker.
Left click and scroll.
Alright.
Nice.
Hello, Sonic.
Whoa!
The sensitivity, though.
Can I grab this?
No, I can't.
Can I grab Sonic, though?
Okay.
Right click to focus.
Left click while focus is recorded.
Alright, Sonic.
I'm gonna grab you real quick.
Alright.
We're gonna have you...
we're gonna have you on the car now be whoa sonic i need you
on top of the car sonic please wait is that a diaper sonic
is that is that sonic chill wait when you're done walk
through the exit to okay all right oh hey this toss a ball
dad okay i love my dad all right let's make a story Sonic.
I need you to Okay.
There you go.
I need you to stay here.
Alright?
Alright, Sonic.
I need you to say I love my dad.
Alright?
But we all know you have daddy issues though.
Alright.
Here you go.
I love my dad.
Alright.
And then.
What happens.
Is that.
Is that you throw a ball.
Oh my God.
We throw the ball up in the sky.
Wait, where'd the ball go?
Wait, where'd the fuck did the ball go?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Alright, alright, the ball is gone.
The ball is now gone forever.
Alright, oh, there's the ball!
Okay, okay, we're gonna put you under the car because, uh, a
car you got, now you have, uh, you're gonna commit insurance
fraud.
Because dad suggested you to commit some insurance fraud.
Because dad is not doing so well financially right now.
So we have to film this for insurance.
All right.
We need to put you under here.
How do we lead from insurance fraud to playing catch?
It's all right.
This is a very low budget film.
All right.
Nice.
Good job, Sonic.
This is fun.
All right.
And I'm done.
Wait.
Yeah, and I'm done.
exit how do i leave oh i have to film fully okay what else
can we do wait what's over here i came from here all right
and now we'll fix it in post yeah we're gonna fix this in
post shout out thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
it's like taking candy from a baby which is a fine by me and
then after that after that you just want to go home You're
done.
You just wanted to go home.
You didn't want to be here anymore.
Yay!
Films done.
Head for the exit.
Alright.
This is a snail.
The
feeder is sold out?
Oh my god!
Let's go home!
It's beautiful!
Look at this.
that i love my dad this is fun let's go home is that great
i'm so proud of sonic i'm so
what a beautiful movie it got sold out too oh my god i am a
great director all right next scene absolute cinema right
there pulling me what is this oh it's primate don't
worry okay I need to know if I can I cannot adjust the
sensitivity Sonic it's time oh my god okay all right here
you go it's okay you're gonna be oh my god Rouge the bat too
oh my god Sonic you know how to pick women wait you're like
stuck to each other wait this is not good wait guys you're
not supposed to be stuck to each other yet not yet okay
let's dance and then we're gonna have close-up we're gonna
have a close-up shots of a pineapple for like um and also
the ice cream yes yes a close-up shot the ice cream oh my
god perfect all right and then after that let's have like a
side shot from the side as if i'm like a voyeur right here
oh yeah you go son like right here as if i'm a voyeur
and then and then we'll slowly scroll closer and there you
go it's good there
Wait, there's more?
Oh,
I have filters.
Oh, my God.
I forgot about that.
I forgot about.
Oh, my God.
I forgot about the filters.
Hey, it's good that I didn't find.
It's good that I didn't find these.
Okay, let's head out.
to the exit all right let's let's leave guys i'm glad wait
there's more what's this that is they just take a picture of
me all right what's this okay it's all right we're good this
film is over oh i should put in night vision i know now that
i know now that i know there's like filters we can have like
black and white films to show that it's like you know uh
it's a hit i knew it oh it's perfect i can have black and
white films because they're extra classy it's extra classy
you know that's like oscar worthy right there chat it's
oscar worthy when you know it's black and white film noir
exactly film noir right there we i knew I had some cinema
fanatics right there That I know exactly what I'm Oh Oh it's
a hotel That's classier than a motel You know Good for them
Good for them that they can afford A hotel Why is there a
What is this?
Why is there a fan here?
Good for them that they can afford A hotel Instead of a
motel Um Cause it's like prom night You know There Oh no
It's University Prom Night.
It's...
Wait, it's...
It's University...
Wait, check the alley?
Where's the alley?
Where's...
Is this the alley?
What's in the alley?
Guys, we don't hear anything in the side.
Guys, don't worry.
Is this...
is this the alley we'll check the room later i just wait who
the fuck is that who are you hello you're an egg is this egg
man origins i love tails but i'm so shy who are you eggie oh
god i thought oh my god that's scared me.
I thought, like, I, he, like, teleported in front of me.
Oh, my God!
Astral, thank you for the one gifted ship.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I thought he actually teleported in front of me.
I was gonna be like, holy shit.
That's his lore.
He likes tales.
All right, here we go.
Let's head on.
Modern Saturn games.
would never do stuff like this anymore they don't they don't
like fucking you know go out of their comfort zone it makes
me so upset wait tails tails what's going on tails what's
going on oh okay film noir wait wait this is worse no way oh
my god shadow
but what about oh okay okay we got it i'm gonna okay because
i feel bad for your tails all right all right we're gonna
put you in there tails i feel so bad for you don't yeah
tails oh we actually get tails out of here actually no amy
wait who are you attached to somebody no you're not all
right here you go all right you're gonna be in the corner
tails is you're subbing out for tails right here you're
subbing out for tails tails want to have fun okay not this
all right there you go all right nice okay i'm lonely and
now we gotta have close-ups of this of this very fun time.
Wait!
Sonic, no, that's Tails!
Sonic, no!
That's Tails!
Wait, bring Tails to Iggy?
Alright, Tails.
Alright, we're gonna include a surprise third.
Alright, Tails, come over here.
We're gonna give you love.
We're gonna find you love!
It's all right.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
As we all know, Sonic characters are always thinking about
protection.
Guys, don't worry.
Stay safe, kids.
College students.
Stay safe.
Because this is university prom night.
Stay safe, university students.
All right, Eki, get over here.
Get over here.
All right, here you go, Iggy.
Here you go.
Oh!
My dream.
What the fuck is that?
Why is there a fire with hearts?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this?
Are you happy now, Mr. Iggy?
Can I bring this over?
Farry passionate Doll, thank you for the super chat Thank
you, thank you Oh my god, this is so trippy It's burning
What is this game?
It's the best Sonic game they've ever made What do you mean?
This is the best Sonic game that's ever created God I can't
Why would I need to remind you guys over You can tell this
is a really good game.
Like, you can tell.
There should be no reminding you of this.
Of this fact.
This was our childhood.
When we were university students.
University childhood.
Alright.
What was this movie like?
Whoa.
Look at that.
The clothes.
okay the close-up is really good i really like the choice of
that i really i think like i about did myself with the
close-up the best one yeah honestly all right next scene
wait try using Dean.
Wait, what?
Where's the camera?
Huh?
Oh.
But where's the camera?
Sonic?
You're not Sonic 2?
What's going on, Sonic?
Oh!
Where's my...
Where's my camcorder?
We're...
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god, thank god, I thought I was gonna miss out.
Oh, thank god, okay, thank- Okay, now we're fine.
Alright.
Getting a close-up of your stomach to know that...
Uh...
To know that it's growing.
Oh, thank- thank god, okay, I thought I was gonna miss out.
I thought I was gonna miss out on this recording.
I think- I- I'm so happy.
I- I mean, I got this.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, yeah, like that.
And then we need the grainy.
Feed me more.
There you go.
And then close up here.
Feed me more.
Nice.
All right, and then now we're going to feed you.
We're going to feed you now.
All right, do you like...
Here you go.
Oh!
Look at that.
I think we can keep feeding you, Sonic.
eat up eat up and be a good boy eat up sonic oh nice all
right i think we can keep feeding you come on you can get
bigger than that sonic eat it for the oscars don't you want
a golden globe sonic you know you want a golden globe
Please, don't keep going.
Guys, this is important.
We won an Oscar.
Oh, you want more?
You did say you want to feed me more.
No, it's not good.
Okay, I thought they were going to cut me off.
Come on, Sonic.
You know you want more.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
They took it away!
Oh, Tails!
Happy birthday, Tails!
Can I feed Tails?
We eat Tails?
You're not gonna eat Tails.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna leave now.
I think we're starting the movie.
Oh, like, it gives me chills, look!
Feed me more.
Yes, feed me more.
Okay, the glitch effect is actually really good.
Not gonna lie, the glitch effect really sells this for me.
It is like, I'm honestly improving more and more as a
director.
Cass, it's better not wake up at something would have hit
me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not gonna lie.
I think I'm... Oh my god!
Is someone Pregante?
Who's Pregante?
Who's the father?
It's shadow?
Where's the camera, though?
Where's the camera?
Oh!
Oh god, wait, wait, don't do anything, Sonic!
Not yet!
Sonic!
Sonic, not yet!
I need to find...
I need to find the camera!
No, not yet!
Please stop smashing the glass.
Never.
There it is!
Oh my god, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, I got the camera.
I'm not the father.
I'm the father.
Who's gonna be the father?
Okay.
Alright guys, who's gonna be the father?
It has to be Eggman.
It has to be Eggman!
Let me in!
I need to get to Eggman!
Right now!
Get over here!
This is for my movie!
Give me Eggman!
Eggman, we need to be the father!
Get over here!
I'm casting you as the father!
Okay.
all right you can sort of see it here there we go all right
this works i'm the father all right ask me how to avoid
rashes okay all right that's good enough uh we'll put it's
not easy at being pregnant right here and then i'm gonna put
a filter uh let's see it's not a horror film anymore so we
should do black and white It's a black and white film right
now.
This is going to be Oscar worthy.
This is what's going to get me an Oscar.
We're going to put this in Best Director of 2024.
All right.
It's not easy being pregnant.
And then we're going to be, Amy's going to be like right
after like we smash through this.
Came out.
Oh my god.
The child comes out, and then Amy's gonna be like, Great
job, Sonic!
Okay.
Alright, I gotta make sure I get this.
Wait, no?
Come on.
Oh, nice!
We got it!
We got the shot!
Oh my god, and it's the- And it's the only shot that's in
color.
There's gonna be the only shot that's in color.
And then...
get get me out of here okay we're gonna close up on this
there we go okay we're gonna move this closer to where the
baby's coming out and then okay no the angle's not right
here this is where the angle is gonna be all right get me
out of here good all right here we go wait actually I need
Let me move here more.
There we go.
Get me out of here.
All right.
One more.
That has to be the last one, right?
Oh, and it was Tails all along!
What?
Congratulations!
Big Man and Tails!
Okay.
It's a miracle.
The miracle of childbirth.
Oh my god.
beautiful so fucking beautiful it truly is a miracle how do
I get out rated e for it by the way this game was like rated
e for everybody guys uh writer thank you for the 10 gift
that shows thank you thank you duck thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you truly a cinematic masterpiece a24
would never be the director Doki.
Wait, what?
Rouge the Bat?
Nightcore?
What the fuck is going on?
There's more?
I don't have enough film!
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, no.
Where am I?
oh my god but look at this oh my god it's not easy
okay okay that shot with the with the chow was really good i
would say i actually captured I filmed that scene perfectly.
Oh my god.
You can feel the trauma and the intensity of everything
right now.
You can really feel it, guys.
You can capture those moments.
Oh my god.
Oscar nominee right there.
Username.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is a weird Yakuza side quest, Sega.
Look, Yakuza took its inspiration.
from Sonic Movie Maker.
Um, you guys didn't know that.
You guys didn't know that.
Look, a rowdy crowd!
Oh, no.
Look, I got an emerald.
Yay!
Wow, this is a really...
This is a really damp cave, guys!
Hello, Iggy.
What do you want, Iggy?
guys it's just it's just a really damp cave guys it's just a
really damp cave guys look at this beautiful cave that i'm
in okay because we're in a cave we need to use the the
grainy film oh my god look at that let's do a close-up of of
this um dilating cave
holy shit you know man i really hate it when my cave my cave
walls starts oh no which way does this go
god don't you hate it when you're exploring the cave and it
gets like super what the fuck is that big Bing the cat?
What are you doing here?
Oh my god!
What the fuck are you doing here?
Why are you doing my cave?
It's okay.
We're gonna...
We're fine.
We're gonna... We found the cave.
exit guys we found where did the cave go oh my god where did
the cave go guys
wait what what does that say smile for mommy oops did you
have an accident Okay, let's just pull this closer to me.
Okay.
Alright, and then...
Then we'll have Taylor's over here.
And be like, wait, what the fuck are you guys?
You guys just got bored.
What are you guys doing?
Mama!
Alright!
Guys, I found the cave's exit, guys.
Whoa!
Wait, what's over there?
I can't see that.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
I'm trying to scroll.
Scroll.
Get over here.
I want to know what that says.
Will I ever figure out what that says?
I can't pull it closer.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
It's getting closer.
What is this?
What does it say?
We want nothing more.
I guess we'll never know what that said.
I guess we'll never know.
I...
I don't know.
I guess we'll never know, guys.
We'll never know.
Alright, this one's not my best work.
I'll have to admit.
This one was definitely not my best work.
I could have done so much better.
There was a lot going on.
There were too many producers.
Okay, guys.
Too many producers were in the room.
Not my best work.
Sorry, you were masked.
Thank you.
Look, a voice actor who has lots of experience being in like
top rated games.
can tell when this is a masterpiece that's when you know
it's good that's when you know it's good guys that is
literally an endorsement right there they were in What the
fuck?
Oh, that's a wrap!
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I can't believe it!
The Doki Bird endorsed by Genshin Impact as one of the best
directors out there.
With this as my proof.
Okay, I don't know what signed guest book.
is so I'm a little worried I'm gonna I'm gonna cover this
real quick sign guest book oh your connection is not private
okay I'm not gonna sign anything we're not gonna guys we're
not gonna sign anything don't say that you guys I'm not
gonna sign anything at the moment so we're not going to
we're not going i went to the website and it was like your
connection is not private and i was like that's that's weird
that's weird oh my god okay all right we're gonna we're
gonna go back to the title screen look at that sonic dream
team yay hey download content wait If I sign in, do I get
the content?
Do I get the content?
So how do I...
Guys, so how do I...
Get my adapter?
Get me the adapter.
Alright, there we go.
I told you every game just gets better and better.
Guys, how do I get my...
adapter guys how do i get my network adapter where's the
password what the fuck is the password you guys said i would
find a password and username and sonic movie maker oh is it
from my roommate sonic oh okay okay okay that's fine that's
fine whoa whoa we'll do their best game yet um this was
considered um the best game they've ever made in the
collection from what I've heard okay I'm gonna make sure I
like I like write this down so my roommate Sonic 99 is
considered one of the best games they've uh they've ever uh
they've ever made in this collection um I've never played
this before but I assume that it's considered better than
Sonic Movie Maker so if it's better than Sonic Movie Maker
then this might be true peak gaming at that point this game
was my childhood see look at that this person seems like
somebody that's played my roommate Sonic made in 1999 at
least like a hundred times also back then they were like
testing out the rift back then in 1999 so in 1999 the first
Oculus Rift prototype was used to test out my roommate Sonic
if you guys didn't know that it's a little fun fact a little
a little small fun fact chat
thanks thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Thank you, Director Doki, for bringing Sonic Dreams
Collection to a modern audience.
God save us all.
Don't worry, 90s kid.
I knew you guys want this.
All right.
Oh, hey, Sonic.
Hey there.
Oh, you and me?
Whoa.
Have you told your roommate how you feel about them?
Um.
What, take the call?
Oh, I don't believe you.
you okay seize life hold up one second look out your window
oh shit just follow my lead okay okay man what do i do why
did you do bro give him the tickles
is this like okay okay is this we're watching hedgehogs
naked hedgehogs are we watching are we watching porn is this
oh i tickle you am i tickling you right now are you are you
feeling a little ticklish in sonic how do i do Tickle!
I'm clicking!
Instructions unclear!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I'm sorry.
I should have asked permission.
I'm so sorry.
Come on, Sonic.
Don't you want to get tickled?
Yeah, you do!
Oh!
Go for that.
kill what does that mean oh but he doesn't like it sonic can
i tickle you okay oh oh
sonic please please you know you want the tickle what is my
life now what is
I'm bad thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
give him the take those jokies why is your feet like this
it's supposed to be cute look at his feet oh my god where
did the rings come from Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Stair deep in his eyes.
Big Ben.
Are you watching this, you sick.
Fuck.
Oh, oh, no, oh, no, no, no.
You take it in.
No!
It's too far.
Oh my god.
That's me Never go Never Never go full tickle Guys Here's a
lesson to all of you Never go fucked Yeah Bump bump Bump
bump bump bump Bump bump bump I hope this is what you wanted
Yay Guys, I realized why the music is playing all the time
It's because I've been on the Sega network this entire time
Bonus siege unlocked!
So that's why we're getting double the music I am so sorry
Wait, I missed the password!
It's okay That's why we were having double the music I had
the Sega a network on this entire time so we were getting
two music it's okay it works it worked in the end all right
sounding movie we got bonus stage bonus stage i thought it
was intentional what's the bonus DLC what is it roommates oh
we're just roommates guys whoa wait how do i get there we're
just very we're just like best friends.
Wait, how do I grab?
How do I grab this?
Give me the camera.
I want the camera.
How do I grab the camera?
But I want...
Whoa!
I want to film things!
Oh!
Oh my god, they're looking at me.
How do I...
How do I get the camera?
Sonic!
What do I do?
Do I just...
Okay.
We'll use this and push it.
Oh!
Your entire head!
Okay.
Alright, I figured it out, guys.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Give me the head.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
I'm holding it.
I'm pulling it back to me.
I'm pulling it back.
Yes.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
Wait, there's another egg.
There's another egg over there.
Wait, but like, how do we make this a story?
You're not going to be tickling anymore.
You're not going to be tickling.
How is this a story?
You're not tickling anymore.
Alright.
Ooh.
Yeah, this feels right.
This.
This feels right.
Okay.
Oh my god, I can play Snake.
Okay, this is gonna be the...
This is the movie.
Guys, guys, I'm gonna be streaming.
Hello everybody.
My name is Doki Bird, and today, we're going to be playing
Snake in Sonic Dreams Collection.
First off, I broke the key.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
Nice.
Look at me go.
This is my 2007 Let's Play.
You know what?
That's great.
I think that's good.
I think that's a good film.
oh my god good special effects award let's go you guys like
my my 2007 um let's play video right here sorry 1999 1998 i
forgot sorry sonic movie maker came out 1998 did you guys
like my 1998 uh 98 this sonic let's play video guys nice
okay rap party is the same party the first let's play i
basically made the first let's play it takes a village all
right we did it all right now now we should be able to down
Now, we should be able to make my Sonic OC.
Okay, I saved.
Somebody gave me the username and password.
Do not worry.
Someone paid $5 for this.
Someone paid $5.
So we got this.
All right.
Log in.
Allow access, please.
the servers whoa can't see all this happening right now but
a lot of stuff is happening oh wow downloading so many
things you hear that that's me downloading stuff right now
10 40 50 60 70 80 90 100 do I have it server launch
operation complete warning is running at full speed is that
it they got it to work can I can I get in now can I message
of the day March 15th 1998 who's I don't even want to say
this name out loud I don't some guy Yeah, that's basically
what it says.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let me upload my OC again.
We'll test it out.
We'll test it out by uploading my OC.
All right.
I still...
Do we still...
We still have her!
Oh my god.
She's still there.
Wait, I think it got uploaded.
It is!
Oh my god.
We have...
We have sexy outfit.
Oh my god.
god this is it we're in all right the big finale the
unreleased the unreleased uh sonic mmo rpg um wait what do
you mean no character data what do you mean
what about sexy outfit
she's real to me she is real
you need the code make another i have to i have to upload my
oc but like how it's not there anymore it's not there where
did the upload go where did it go Oh, I just need to take a
screenshot.
Okay.
I almost forgot.
Where's the back?
Ooh, okay.
A little bit of the leg kicking out right here.
And then boom.
There it is!
Okay, I'm going to upload it.
I'm really worried.
So I'm going to unhide that real fast.
I'm going to hide that real fast.
Oh, it just says this.
Upload success!
There we go.
Yay!
Sexy outfit, let's go!
Alright, now we have our character.
Now we have our character.
Here we go.
Eggman Origin.
What happened to your body?
Your body!
How can you be sexy about our body?
Alright, log in.
Where am I?
Is this me?
That's me.
Where can we go?
What's going on?
Hello.
Hello there.
Sexy legs.
Even better.
But where's my butt?
Hello?
What are you supposed to do?
Big man?
Where do I go?
Where is sexy outfit gonna go?
Am I...
Am I going the right way?
Guys, anyone else created an account in Eggman Origins?
Did anyone else...
Did anyone else create an account?
Sure that you guys know where to go, right?
I like it.
So I was like, I got banned.
I got banned.
sorry we can't help you wait let me i'm gonna turn off the
sega net surely somebody's all where are all my friends at
oh the shadow loop is an enigma i'm a hundred years old oh
okay where am i where where am i where do i go Oh, where do
I go?
Where do I go, Mr. Eggie?
Mr. Eggie, I'm lost!
I'm lost!
Okay, maybe it's this way.
It has to be this way.
Where else can we go?
Is it this way?
Oh, there's another Mr. Eggie!
Oh!
Oh, get me out of the void!
pessimistic egg we can't be lost we just have to go up the
never-ending expanse is kind of scary is that am i going the
right way this is it is this a new sport sequel no sport is
the sequel to egg man origins guys neo thank you for the
super chat thank you where am i Where the fuck am I?
Where am I?
Oh, that's the wall!
I think the worst part is that I can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
That's the void!
Somebody get me out!
What do we mean turn on the camera?
Ow!
I'm just legs!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Okay, that's a wall.
That's... I'm lost!
I'm lost!
No wonder they canceled.
Oh god, oh god.
like a dark journey into limbo the realm between heaven hell
a purgatory for sonic fans boyton thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you hit towards your camera okay you're
right you're right i'll eventually find my way if i keep
walking backwards there has to be another egg somewhere.
This is what my sleep paralysis even looks like.
We're in Canada.
Oh my god.
Bro, this map is huge.
This isn't MMORPG.
Oh my final fantasy wishes it can be just this.
Oh my god, another egg!
Another egg!
Friend?
Friend!
Where am I friend?
I try to take a nap in the shade, but I can't sleep.
Wait, do I follow the shadow?
Maybe if I follow the shadow.
Wait, click the cloud.
What's the cloud?
Where did the cloud go?
What's that?
What the fuck is that?
I feed Mr. Egg!
Oh my god, I know now.
I know now.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Eggman.
I'm gonna make you big and strong.
Feed into Egg.
Oh my god, I know now.
I know now.
The objective.
My purpose in life.
Alright, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Don't worry.
Now I know why I'm all eggs.
Now I know why.
Iggy.
Igbat, where are you?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Here you go, child.
Oh, he's turning big.
He's a big boy now.
Kari, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't think my dreams are going to be pleasant tonight.
What are you talking about?
Don't you want to tickle Sonic?
Don't you want to tickle him?
I'm a little lost.
Is this where my child is?
Here you go.
Become big and strong for sexy outfits.
whoa okay she's definitely becoming big and strong i don't
know there's any clouds in the back but any clouds in the
back or is it all forward this is a real turkey simulator i
didn't say treat an egg baby good to get an award and not
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you this game
was made before yellow paint guides, and it is a masterpiece
for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're at the worms.
Guys.
It's just the void.
Oh, there's a worm.
There's a worm right here.
Worm.
I need to feed my baby egg.
Get over.
over here worm boop boop all right nice all right back to
mr.
egg man i wish i can run i wish i can run faster this is the
dragoons origin story sorry thank you for this magenta soup
thank you thank you dear miss jokie bird my therapist will
be Because he had a great time?
Because he had a great time?
I did.
Alright, here we go.
This is all.
Do you need more worms?
Are you big and strong now?
Oh.
We need more?
But where am I gonna find more?
Where am I gonna find more?
You've had so many!
I'm just...
Oh, there's more!
more.
I'm just a single hard-working bird mom.
Where else am I gonna find more?
Okay, here we go.
There's another worm.
Alright, here.
Is that it?
How much more?
How much more do you want?
Hector, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Psychologist, all dreams have meaning my dreams.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, where did he go?
Am I going the right?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay, this is where he is.
All right, here we go.
This is all, this is it?
Are you, are you good now?
Are you full?
Oh.
more do you want you want more we're gonna find more i can
feed six how many did i get oh wait wait how many did i get
oh my god i've lost count i've lost count how much more do i
need evil thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
just join i feel like i need I have found four.
Oh my god.
This is stupid.
Why can't the worms just come to me?
There's one.
There's one right here.
Oh my god.
There's one here.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We got this.
Don't worry, Eggman.
Mama's coming back with another worm.
Child care is not stupid.
Okay.
Look, you don't understand how hard it is to be a single
bird mom.
You don't know the hard life it is.
Why are you trying to find going out there in the void?
Trying to find six fucking worms for your demanding egg
child.
There you go.
it takes a village exactly it takes a fucking village oh my
god i my sonic oc was supposed to be in the void to be sexy
not to find worms
right side okay to the right to the right here i go Where is
this worm?
Now she's all.
Oh, there it is.
There's the last one.
There you are.
I'm coming over.
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
It is sexy.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I got the final worm.
The final worm for my child.
It's coming.
Don't worry.
Mama's coming to feed you.
Okay, I think I'm going the right way.
And finally...
Your OC is looking sexy.
Finding worms.
Okay, but there's a lot to unpack there.
That is a lot to unpack there, sir.
All right, here it is.
All right, here we go.
Igman.
Igman, I got your worm.
Your final worm.
Are you happy now?
Oh.
what the fuck
what oh my god oh my god now he's now he's a mama too he
gave birth to a fucking podium I'm so proud of you I'm a
grandma now I'm a a son I'm a grandma now look at that i got
my own i got my own grandson he's got a chair
oh my god look at him go now he's also a single parent like
what what what are you doing what
one out of a thousand players
oh sonic has ascended you have one ascension god in the sky
submit your name to paradise what was it sexy outfit oh i
can only I can only have like five five characters guys so
I'm gonna submit this sexy
that's that's gonna be my name guys that's gonna be my thing
apparently I can't have more than five characters so that's
gonna be my name that's gonna be my name yay we did it oh is
my audio cutting in and out does the game break my audio
no it's okay on my end on my end it's okay The stream was
like Is it better now?
Holy shit Holy shit Is it better now?
I said it's so hard The stream died I said the YouTube I
ascended And then the game just shut down The YouTube just
shut down They're like we can't handle this anymore Wow That
was it That was the Sonic Dream Collection.
I'm so happy to be able to share this game with all of you.
I...
The game couldn't handle.
Yeah!
I enjoyed my stay.
I'm so happy to share you a game.
game from the 90s um you guys all keep saying doki we want
you to play retro games doki when are you gonna play retro
games again doki look see i literally played four retro
games for all of you all in one stream and i shared with you
uh i shared with you the best sonic game that was ever made
for the Sonic franchise.
It was really exciting.
I'm really happy to be able to share this with all of you.
I think, I think, like, not gonna lie, my director skills,
10 out of 10.
I think I, like, improved so much.
Uh, I improved so much in directing, and, like, um, and,
like, producing and, like, camera angles, and the, the Dutch
angle, and film noir.
Oh, my God.
all of those scenes 10 out of 10 honestly
oh my god holy shit i'm happy to be able to share it with
you guys that was like honestly one of the one of the games
that i've always wanted to play on stream so i'm glad that
yeah every every every level i just get better and better
and better in the whole like film like in the I just kept
getting better and better and better.
Zonderman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel fed.
Thank you, Doki.
True cinema, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Igor, thank you for the five gift that shows.
Shadow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Today is finally my birthday.
I love your streams.
It fills my day with laughter.
You get a happy birthday in Cantonese.
Thank you for today's stream.
Thank you for the super chat, Shadow.
Sci-fi law.
little concerning that the the actually no it's a gift it's
a gift that on your birthday you get to watch this stream
this is the stream that was that was made for your birthday
you should be honored to be able to watch this on your
birthday um not gonna lie happy birthday to you Happy
birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Shadow.
Happy birthday to you.
Yay!
Max, I really got, never really got art games until now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, so honestly, honestly, best, uh, I wish AAA games were
made like this again.
I feel like, not gonna lie, like a lot of AAA games, they
just, they just can't do it.
Like, A lot of AAA, they just fell off.
They just don't know what the audience really...
Don't know what gamers actually want these days, you know,
with AAA game titles.
So it's really nice to go back to, like, when games were
actually fun.
Oh my god.
It's really great to relive back in the days when they just
knew what we wanted.
They just knew exactly what we wanted.
in a AAA game title.
And back then, Sega knew exactly what Sonic fans wanted in a
game title.
And that's why Sonic Dream Collection is Game of the Decade
in the 90s.
When they...
Especially my roommate, Sonic.
Sonic fans rejoiced
when Sega finally succumbed to the Sonic fandom's demands.
You know that all Sonic fans back then in 1999 were so
fucking happy about my roommate Sonic.
It was a it was truly a Christmas gift for all Sonic fans.
When will we ever get Sonic Dreams remake?
Sega!
You're out here remaking, remastering so many Sonic games.
I want a remaster of Sonic Dreams.
Alright.
That's all I want.
That's all I want in life.
Nick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is why the Dreamcast found us at Council.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Henry, thank you for the Super Chat.
I'm still trying to figure out what I was watching.
Peak gaming.
That is what you were watching.
I know, like, it's hard to recognize it because of all the
garbage we've been given over the recent years from gaming
companies.
But, like, I know, like, you have, like, a little bit, like,
some Stockholm syndrome at the moment from, like, all the
fucking slop we've been given from, like, AAA gaming.
rings but like back then that is what we call real game a
real video game and all that entire collection in the 90s
was just 599 is that crazy it wasn't 40 dollars with like a
50 dollar DLC back then you can buy one CD for 599 and it
contained all those games in the Sonic Dreams collection.
True value.
If you're lucky, you might even find it in your local thrift
store.
Steam, or Steam's a coward.
Sega's a fucking coward for not releasing it on Steam.
Look, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That is my first quadruple.
Drupal A game.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh,
I made quadruple.
It's a quintuple game.
Put in.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doki, for making tomorrow rest day so we can see
our therapist tomorrow.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, to tell them about the great time you had watching it
right right guys talk about your experience with how much
fun you had enjoying this in this stream with your therapist
um so i think you're gonna super chat thank you thank you
this game was very was indeed very keynote kubrick is
envious thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
right guys i'm going to call it here now i love to chat with
I have a lot of work to do.
I know I keep saying that I haven't been able to do a long
chatting stream with all of you guys.
But I've just been so busy almost every day.
And I hope that things calm down soon.
So we can have our usual chatting streams where you can just
chat after the game.
But at the moment, there's just so much work to do,
especially in preparation for the charity stream on
Saturday.
So I really do apologize that we have to come.
cut it short but I hope you guys had a fun time watching me
play Sonic Dreams Collection it's honestly one of the games
I've been wanting to stream for a very long time so I'm
happy to be able to finally experience uh experience this
game with all of you but thank you guys uh cheat I'll read
this last super chat thank you a super chat thank you thank
you I listened to the stream while driving home from work
today audio only so I had zero context for anything I just
keep hearing about feeding sonic and pregnant that is enough
context that you need don't worry that's all you need do not
worry but thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
alright guys as always everybody say hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that blood flowing and then
you say out for me head to bed because you deserve it I'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye